believe there's growing support across
Parliament for the compelling case there
is to answer the call from our allies to
act against ISIL in Syria and in Iraq
the headquarters many ways of the
terrorists that she is in Syria and it
makes no sense to recognize this border
in the action we take when I saw
themselves don't recognize this border
so it's in the national interest it's
the right thing to do will be acting
with our allies will be careful and
responsible as we do so but in my view
it's right to do this to help to keep
our country safe Jeremy consent he wants
to to database you're not going to do
well we'll make sure that we have a very
long and full debate on Wednesday and
we'll take the action necessary to make
sure that we have in many ways the
equivalent number of hours that you
often have across a two-day debate in
one day I want MPs to be able to have
full consideration to make speeches to
make points to ask me questions to
examine the government's case as we did
for two and a half hours in the House of
Commons last week one of the
uncertainties about seventy thousand
troops that you say moderates on the
ground who are they where are they and
I'll be sure that they're the people we
want to try and racket well the 70,000
figure was provided to me by my experts
and that's why I made that point in the
House of Commons obviously in Iraq we
have ground troops there in terms of the
Iraqi army and the Kurdish Peshmerga
forces as I said last week the Syrian
situation is more complicated but there
are some ground troops in terms of Free
Syrian Army and other troops that are
able to take action against ISIL but in
any event it is right for us when the
action we've taken has been successful
in Iraq it's shrunk ISIL territory by
thirty percent it's damaged their
infrastructure it's set them back it's
right to extend that action to Syria but
let's be clear there is no military
solution to this issue the action we are
taking is part of a broader strategy a
political strategy a diplomatic strategy
a humanitarian strategy and in the end
the answer to what is happening in Iraq
and in Syria is the same we need good
strong government's that represent all
of their people Sunni share curd
Christian and Drew's that is right for
Iraq it's right for Syria it will take
time this whole strategy will take time
but it's the right thing to do to make
sure we go after the terrorists who
threaten people in our country just as
they attacked and killed those people on
the streets of Paris on the streets of
Ankara on the streets of Beirut and
indeed British people on the beaches of
cheer